They might be more famous Outlaws out there who rooms the wild West,
but few of them, if any, with deadlier, the John Wesley Hardin,
he brags about gunning down over 40 men.
Although newspapers of the time were only able to corroborate around 25 victims
even. So this is still a lot more than other notorious gunman of the time,
such as Billy, the kids, Jesse James,
or wild bill Hickok harden branded himself, the deadliest killer of them all.
But as you were about to find out,
he was also a man who was a little more interested in creating an image for
himself. Then speaking the truth, there are many claims he made,
which at this point are simply impossible to corroborate fully like the time he
killed a man for just snoring too loudly. But at the same time,
he said for most other figures of the wild West and most of the figures on this
channel, in fact, when you become famous and enough time passes,
the truth always gets mixed in with a bit of exaggeration and legend.
So we will do our best as we bring you the violence and bloody story of the
outlaw John Wesley hall.
Right?
So we should point out that a lot of the details surrounding Hodan,
particularly his early life,
come to us straight from the man himself and are completely unsubstantiated by
any other sources.
He actually wrote an autobiography in prison titled the life of John Wesley
Hardin, which was published in 1896,
shortly after his death Hardin was born on may the 26th,
1953 in bond and Texas,
the son of a Methodist preacher named James harden and his wife,
Elizabeth Dixon.
They did a lot of traveling throughout the state when harden was a young boy
because his father was a circuit rider,
meaning that he was an itinerant clergyman who traveled from one settlement to
another to organize congregations.
Eventually the family settled down in Sumpter, Trinity County,
where James harden served as a teacher until the outbreak of the civil war in
1861, according to his son's autobiography,
the senior harden immediately wanted to join the Confederate army,
but was convinced to stay behind as he would be more useful in his hometown
housing himself had wanted to go off fighting Yankees,
although he was only nine at the time,
and even made a plan with his older brother, Joe,
to run away and join the Confederacy. However,
that master plan was foiled when their father found out about it and beat them
until they came to their senses,
the civil war had a serious impact on the development of a young harden.
He became a typical Confederacy supporter who considered slavery.
The white man's writings represented all minorities,
but particularly black people.
There was only a few more years until John Wesley Hardin first showed off his
extremely violent nature in 1867,
the 14 year old heart and got into a fight with another boy called Charles
slaughter and both drew their knives,
pardoned stabbed the other boy twice and nitty Kilton. He claimed this.
He acted in self-defense and presumably convinced the school's officials.
If this fact is he avoided any serious consequences while salsa might've avoided
Hardin's facial wrath. It was only a year later that the future outlook guilt,
his first man, a former slave named MEJ. Again, according to harden,
this was also self-defense, which is a recurring theme in his autobiography.
As he constantly portrays himself,
either as a victim or someone completely justified in his actions,
as he succinctly put it, the people that he killed needed killing harden,
and his cousin got into a wrestling match with the form of slave.
The two boys won while hot and even drew blood from MEJ something which enraged
him to the point of wanting to shoot out the 15 year old heart and was not one
to back down. So he went home to retrieve a gun,
but his uncle got wind of what he intended to do and kept them in the house.
The next day harden was out riding when he met with major, again,
still fills with Von and rage that latter ran into the road and grabbed Hardin's
horse by the bridle that's which point it's the former pulls out a Colt 40
foreign shop made four times.
[Inaudible].
Only a few days later and hardened saw himself forced to go on the run again in
his own version of events, haunting painted himself as the victim.
One who would have never received proper justice from the courts as they became
filled with Northern bureaucrats and agents and other veterans,
enemies of the South harden had the same buser loading and prejudice for union
soldiers.
This he did for minorities while it's feasible that his first few violent
encounters could have been self-defense.
The third one made it clear that John Wesley Hardin was a cold blooded murderer,
plain and simple.
Soon off to the death of major an arrest warrant was issued for Hardin's arrest.
Thirties got a tip on where he was hiding and sent union soldiers to take him
in. But the outlaw caught wind of the incoming posse from his brother, Joe,
and waited for them in ambush as Arjun himself, put it.
He had no mercy on men who he knew only wanted to get his body to torture and
kill arms with a shotgun and to revolver Hardin waylaid,
the three union soldiers,
guns them all down and it's buried their bodies in the bed of a nearby Creek.
John Wesley Hardin was still just 15 years old and had already killed four
people. Once he was a fully fledged outlaw,
haunting began quickly associating with other criminals throughout Navarro
County, Texas. He rode with Frank Polk for a while,
a gunman pursued by a detachment of soldiers,
killing another man named Tom Brady. The soldiers managed to capture polic,
but harden escapes their grasp. When he was hanging out with Jim Newman,
nodding claims,
he shot a man's eye out just to when a bottle of whiskey and of that.
He played a road for a bit with a cousin of his named simp Dixon,
who was a member of the KU Klux Klan.
They also got into a shootout with some union soldiers and killed two more of
them. In 1869.
Dixon was later captured alone and executed by firing squad later that same year
Hardin left Navarro County and roamed around taxes for a while as expected.
The conflicts and confrontations kept coming one after another,
oftentimes they turned to violence and sometimes even deadly Hardin claims to
have guilt and other four men during this time,
including a pimp and a circus performance in January, 1871,
hardened stood accused of being involved in the murder of city.
Marshall Labon John Hoffman of Waco,
Texas Hoffman was sitting in a barbershop chair with his face,
love waiting for a shave.
When someone walks up behind him and shot him in the back of the head,
killing him instantly the gunman then sped out of town on horseback hiding
claims to be innocence in his autobiography.
Of course his word means nothing but reports at that time,
named him as an accomplice instead of the killer,
while also mentioning another criminal named while George Thomason,
who was apparently gunned down in a shootout with state police.
So it is possible that Thomas was the shooter instead of harden. Anyway,
harden was caught and arrested for a while.
It seems like as outlaw days might've come to an end,
but he still had a few tricks up his sleeve. For some reason,
harden was not held in Waco while awaiting trial.
Instead he was transferred to a small town called Marshall,
where he was kept inside a log cabin and jailed somehow how to manage,
to get his hands on a pistol from another prisoner,
which he kept hidden by tying it with a string under his arm.
He waited for the best opportunity to use it,
which she got when he was being transferred back to Waco on the road,
he was being escorted only by two state policemen, Edward steaks,
and Jim smally.
At one point steaks left to get wood for the fire part and retrieved has gone
well,
smally wasn't looking and killed him before making a run for it on his horse.
Afterwards,
harden hid out in Gonzalez County for a while with some cousins of his named
Clements, he needed to get out of Texas.
So his cousin suggested work as a cowboy driving cattle on the Chisolm trail
between Texas and Kansas, of course, just because he needed to lay low,
did not mean that and left behind his violent ways.
He got into multiple gunfights with Mexican, for chiros,
cattle rustlers and native Americans, which ended in fatalities.
Nobody's really sure how many victims hiding claims, but according to him,
he could've killed up to eight people just in the few months that he served as a
capital drive.
I think the most memorable part of Harden's life occurred in the summer of 1871.
When he made his way to Aberdeen in Kansas.
This is where he had a few run-ins with the local town. Marshall,
who also happened to be one of the old West's most famous icons,
wild bill Hickok. By the way,
if you're not familiar with the many exploits of wild bill,
we've already done a biographics video on him a few months ago.
So maybe go check it out if you want to. Anyway, it went hard and got into town.
He adopted the name Clements after his cousins,
seeing as how you're still a wanted man.
Most people including Hickok apparently called him little Arkansas or,
and it is unclear who, if any, were aware of his true identity. At first,
he got along well with wild bill,
even having a few drinking sessions within then going on cattle drives together.
And this is despite the fact that right off the bat,
other people trying to turn harden against haircare coping that's.
He might be the one to take down the ruthless lawman,
who by that point had already built a fist and reputation for himself.
According to harden, when he arrived in town,
there was an ongoing conflict between the town Marshall and the proprietors of a
local saloon named the bulls had Tavern.
Those proprietors were businessmen Philco and Ben Thompson noted gunman in his
own, right?
They got into a dispute with heck over the logo painted on the side of that
Tavern,
which was a vulgar image of a bull after getting complaints from the locals.
Wild bill told Cohen to change the picture they refused.
So hick brought some painters and he did it himself. Since then,
the two saloon gamers hated wild bills. Godson wants to go gone.
This would have preferred if someone did the dirty work for them and to John
Wesley Hardin, he and Ben Thompson quickly developed an amicable relationship.
Hasn't frequented. The bulls had Tavern,
a loss and Thompson had fought for the Confederacy during the civil war.
And as we've previously mentioned,
haunting was a diehard supporter of the South. Well,
having nothing but murderous scorn for the Northern Yankees as it happens,
wild bill Hickok served the union during the war.
So Thompson saw a great opportunity to sow some dissent.
He whispered in hardened Zare about how Hickok was the typical Yankee who hated
southerners, particularly Texans,
and always shot them dead at the slightest harden,
saw where this was going and said that he had no interest in finding someone
else's battle resorting to Thompson. If bill needs killing,
why don't you kill him yourself? That being said,
Hardin was eager to make it clear that he was not afraid of wild bill hiccup as
soon evidenced by that very first confrontation. And just to be clear,
we're not saying we believe for a minute, this is what actually happens,
but we aren't the story exactly. As told by harden and his autobiography,
one day he was bowling in one of the buildings,
making a lot of noise with a bunch of other Texans.
Hardened still had his guns on it.
And even though he was supposed to disarm when in town,
the Marshall entered the Tavern and told them to keep it cross.
And that's when he sold it hot and was armed.
The two of them exited the saloon peacefully,
but harden acted reluctance to give up his guns, not one known for his patients.
Wild bill drew his own revolver and went to arrest him.
Odense slowly took out his weapons and handed them towards Hickok.
But first the Marshall reacted to grab them hot and quickly spun them around in
his hand so that all of a sudden wild bill,
two barrels in his face and was forced to surrender his own gun.
The trick was known as the road agent spin or the Carney bill spin as if this
wasn't fantastical enough. All of the cities soon gathered around them,
cheering on haunting and encouraging him to shoot ticket debt.
At this point in the Marshall began pleading with the outlaw,
not to let the angry mob gun him down request.
That's the noble and heroic harden acquiesce do by shouting that it was his fine
to learn and that he would kill the first man that finds a gun afterwards
ticket,
tried to befriend harden by telling him you're the game best and quickest.
Boy I ever saw, let us compromise this matter. And I will be your friends.
Let us go in here and take a drink as I want to talk to you and give you some
advice. And the two Indeed's went into a private room,
had a few drinks and came out as friends.
And that's the story of the day that John Wesley Hardin drew on wild bill
Hickok. At this point,
you might be able to see why most wild bill historians didn't take Hardin's
autobiography seriously and consider it more of a presentation of his personal
fantasy than a factual historical accounts.
There are quite a few problems with the story starting off with the idea that
wild bill Hickok, which full of assumption trick in the first place.
It's not impossible,
but it's highly unlikely given how cautious he was around other gunman.
And even if he did even more outlandish was the idea that Hickok would just let
the whole thing go after a few drinks,
especially when harden has just humiliated him in front of the whole town and
basically destroyed his reputation as a fearsome gunslinger.
Then there is also a total lack of other sources is hardened himself was the
only ones who mentioned this event since last but not least harden only started
sharing this tale after HECO could, or.
He died.
But the most infamous moments of the heart and legends,
the nights when he killed a man for snoring,
we should mention that while this event definitely happens,
the details are conflicting.
Although harden himself admitted to the deed at first, quite proudly. In fact,
he later amended the story for his book instead of killing an unsuspecting
defense, the sleeping man,
he sheltered would be robber or even an assassin broke into his room and was
armed with a deck dagger on August the sixth,
1871 hardened put up for the night, the American house hotel in Adelaide.
He went to bed only to discover that the man in the adjacent room was snoring
very loudly.
Whether the man was a complete stranger or a Confederate of hauntings is
uncertain either way. Harden got so annoyed with him,
but he began shooting through the shad wall.
It's unclear if the outlaw intended to kill the man from the outset or if he
just wanted to waken up and scam,
but at least one bullet hit the sleeping man who died in his bed.
Everybody heard the shots and while they may not have realized yet that hot and
killed a man, he still broke the law by shooting his guns within city limits.
And his deputies were on their way. So harden had to make a quick getaway.
He did not have time to get dressed. So he left in his nightclothes.
He climbed his out of his window and onto the porch roof.
He jumped down into the street and hit inside a haystack where he stepped into a
morning. When the sun came hot and crawled through a cornfield,
until he ran into a lone cowboy, installed his horse,
making his exit from Abilene. He would never return a few days later,
a newspaper reported his crime. Simply noting this.
A man was killed in his bed at a hotel in Adelaide,
Monday nights by a Desperado called Arkansas. The matter escapes.
This was his sixth Metta. This shows that at that point,
authorities were still unaware that the gunfighter from Abilene was the same as
John Wesley harden, who was wanted for a lot more than six murders,
whatever the real number was.
It didn't stay the same for long for the rest of the year.
Harden went back to Texas where he was again,
involved in multiple shootouts that resulted in fatalities,
including that of a police officer named green paramour guilds on October the
sixth, 1971, according to reports paramour and another officer names.
John Lackey tried to arrest harden and a general store.
And Noval Gonzales County, the killer pretended to discern, but again,
use the road agents spin again. He shot both officers and made a run for us.
Although Lackey survived his injury.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, 1872. So hard and make an attempt to settle down the marriage.
A woman named Jane Bowen and the couple had three children together.
At one point,
he was injured in the gunfight and turned himself into the authorities,
thinking he was going die,
however hard and made a full recovery and see another change of hearts.
Once he realized that he was going to be charged with multiple murders,
escaped from jail and went on the run again in 1873,
Hardin was in duet County taxes where he found himself embroiled in one of the
longest and bloodiest rivalries of the old West.
The Southern tailor viewed the exact origins of this conflict are a bit murky,
but the animosity between these two families erupted into a full blown feud in
1868, when William Sutton, deputy sheriff and Kenton,
Texas Shelton killed Charlie Taylor during an arrest for horse theft later that
same year Sutton killed another member of the Taylor family named buck,
as well as an associate called Dick Chisolm during a saloon fight.
Hodgkin joins the feud a few years later on behalf of the tailors who were
introduced to him through his cousins, the planets,
by the time the dispute ended in 1876,
thanks to the intervention of the Texas Rangers.
At least 35 people had been killed.
How many of them died at the hands of John Wesley? Hunton is,
I want to say is even he remained vague about his involvement in his book.
He definitely took bonds in the murder of lawman Jack Hallam.
Although he may have been an accomplice while Jim Taylor was the one who
actually pulled the trigger on may the 26,
1874 harden celebrated his 21st birthday by this point had already killed dozens
of men and yet never really suffered any serious consequences for his actions.
But as an ex murder would be the one that would finally land them in hot water
harden was in a saloon in Comanche taxes,
drinking with some of his associates in honor of his birthday.
They got into a fight with deputy sheriff,
Charles Webb and gunned him down pod in himself, managed to make a run for it.
As although some of his accomplices were arrested,
taken to jail and later killed by an angry mob.
This ended Harden's involvement with the Southern Taylor few,
does he have to flee the state traveling first to Alabama and then to Florida,
he was finally captured in 1977 in Pensacola, Florida,
and transferred back to Texas to stand trial.
For some reason. Yeah.
Harden was only charged initially with webs murder for which he received 25
years in Huntsville prison.
He later routed a second two year sentence for another murder,
but as part of a plea bargain and he was allowed to serve both sentences
concurrently at first Harding was a problem.
Inmate getting into multiple fights and being part of several unsuccessful
escape attempts with time. However, he began adapting his prison life.
He spends a lot of time writing his fabricated autobiography.
He became a constant attendant at Sunday school and began studying law books.
Believe it or not Hardin actually passed the lore exam and made a half-hearted
attempt at setting up a legitimate practice.
When he was released before falling back into his old ways,
the Texas governor pardoned Harding,
the good behavior after serving 16 years in 1894,
he went to Gonzalez to be with his kids.
His wife had passed away while he was in prison. This new one reforms hardened,
and it lasted a few months. And before you knew it was back on his own, again,
this time he was located in El Paso, Texas, at one point,
Hardin goes into an altercation with a local law man named John Selman Jr.
After the latter had arrested Hardin's girlfriends,
carrying a gun within city limits,
the fight got pretty heated and the former outlaw threatened Solomon's life.
What of this reach? The young offices, father Johns Elman, senior,
who also had a violent poss like harden serving as both Norman and lawbreaker at
times you understood what kind of man hot him was,
and probably considered him a threat to his family. On the afternoon of August,
the 19th,
1895 Selman ends at the acne saloon where harden was playing dice and shot him
in the back of the head, killing him instantly.
He then brought a few more bullets into his chest for good measure.
Solomon was arrested and tried for Hardin's murder,
but was released following a hung jury.
His defense was that harden had seen him into the saloon in the mirror and was
reaching for his gun.
So he shot him in self-defense Selman was never put on trial again because less
than a year later, he was also killed in a shootout with us. Marshall,
George Scarborough, as for Hardin, he was buried as a local cemetery,
but it kept staring off controversy even a hundred years after his death.
His descendants began petitioning to have him dug up from El Paso and buried in
Nixon, Texas next to his wife, Jane, the residents of El Paso.
You didn't want to give him up because his grave was a popular tourist
attraction. So a lawsuit ensued,
which was eventually ruled in favor of keeping John Wesley Hardin and I'll pass
so well. He's still rests to this day. So I really hope you found this video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and as always, thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].